hi and welcome to veritasium an online
science video blog I'd like to take on
scientific topics all the way from the
simplest to the most complex so a good
place to start I think is with a problem
considered by a famous physicist Richard
Feynman he asked if all the world's
scientific information except for one
sentence were destroyed in some
cataclysmic event which single statement
would contain the most scientific
information for future generations his
conclusion was that it is the atomic
hypothesis the atomic hypothesis states
that all things are made up of atoms
tiny particles that are in perpetual
motion they attract each other when a
little distance apart but repel if
squeezed together that statement is
incredibly important to understand if
you want to understand most of the rest
of science because everything is made of
atoms including you and me and the Opera
House and the Harbour Bridge and the
water and the trees and the grass and
the air and the clouds and well you get
the idea everything is made out of atoms
so it's really important to understand
the atomic concept if you're going to
understand the rest of science the idea
that everything is made of tiny
particles has been around for thousands
of years the oldest recorded texts are
in Greece and India in fact the word
atom comes from the Greek Atomos meaning
literally uncuttable so the idea that
they had was if you took a piece of
matter like this piece of aluminium foil
you could cut it in half
and in half again each time reducing the
number of atoms by half but the idea was
you could not go on doing that
indefinitely for there would come a
point when you have only a single atom
left and it is uncuttable it's an atom
how many times do you think I could cut
this a4 sheet of aluminium in half
before I reach a single atom